the movie opens up in the year 1934 in
Connecticut where former U.S President
John F Kennedy is still in his teenage
years he must have gotten all the babes
one day while at school his math teacher
calls him to his office John obliges and
as soon as he closes the door the
teacher pulls a gun on him trying to
kill him luckily an unnamed man barges
in through the door and shoots the
teacher dead JFK is traumatized by what
just happened following this we are
taken to the year 2018 to present day
Earth inside a basement two men exit a
strange device and slowly bring out an
unconscious John F Kennedy lo and behold
it is revealed that the men are Time
Travelers and that the device is a time
machine
one of the men Wyatt approaches his
awestruck colleagues and explains that
the ritten house tried to assassinate
JFK that's why he and his colleague had
to bring him here here we get to know
that the written house is a mysterious
organization did this movie come out
before Kyle Rittenhouse oh my God I
think it did here we get to know that
the written house is a mysterious
organization whose sole purpose is to
change the course of history in a
negative way they do this with the help
of their time traveling assassins and
this time a 17 year old JFK was their
target the plan was to finish him off
before he could become the president and
change America for the better on the
other hand Wyatt and his associates are
part of the Lifeboat team an
organization whose job is pretty much
just to stop the evil Written House
meanwhile Wyatt promises to his worried
colleagues that he will return JFK back
in his time as soon as the danger is
averted until then he will be staying in
the basement after a while JFK finally
regains Consciousness and starts
bombarding everyone with questions he
inquires about the location and why his
mask teacher tried to kill him why in
the world did that man try to kill me
Wyatt makes up a story that they are
private security hired by his dad but
JFK starts panicking even more
fortunately Lifeboat team has a history
teacher named Lucy and she uses her
knowledge of JFK's family like his
father's name and home address to calm
him down she also reassures him that
he'll meet his father very soon and
until that time he should just rest
following this the Lifeboat team leaves
the room and closes the door so the JFK
can have some alone time Lucy goes to
the kitchen to prepare some food for him
but when she returns after 10 minutes
JFK is nowhere to be seen turns out the
teenager got scared and escaped through
a small tunnel in the basement Wyatt and
the others scanned the whole area and
even contact the security guard outside
but find no traces of the teenager now
they are faced with a challenging task
if they don't find JFK quickly the
written house will probably get to him
first and kill him this will result in
JFK never becoming the president which
in turn will cause a series of chain
events the Peace Corps will cease to
exist the Civil Rights Act will never
happen the immigration reform will be
abolished and most importantly several
countries will be at America's neck who
knows the world may turn into a war zone
run by lunatics don't worry that's going
to happen anyway so why at Lucy and
another colleague decide to go after him
elsewhere JFK reaches a nearby
department store and immediately gets
shocked to witness the technological
advancements like LED television ATM
machine CCTV camera BDSM entertainment
and so on he then heads to the cashier
and asks for a pay phone but gets told
that those things are only found in
museums anxious JFK reveals that he has
been kidnapped and hearing this the
cashier finally takes the situation
seriously and brings out his smartphone
but as expected JFK has no idea how to
use it just then he finds a magazine on
the counter which has the year 2018
written on it JFK nervously asks the
cashier today's date and when the latter
replies April 5th 2018 his mind is blown
even more blown than it was in 63 as he
tries to get a hold of the situation
cars keep pulling up at the store and
this makes him more and more anxious he
believes that the kidnappers from
earlier will find him any second and
take him back to the basement so when a
group of teenagers get ready to depart
he requests a lift one of them named
Kelly mentions that they're going to
Palo Alto and this shocks JFK even more
as he was kidnapped thousands of miles
away in Connecticut nonetheless he
decides to join the group as getting
lost is better than getting apprehended
back at the basement some tech guys are
trying to locate the teenager through
CCTV footage one of them fears that JFK
may already have been found and killed
by the ritten house however his friend
disagrees she comes up with a theory
that since they all know who JFK is he
probably returned back to his time and
became the president so as long as they
know him he is still alive and kicking
elsewhere Wyatt and his team reach the
department store and inquire about the
teenager the cashier suspecting that
they are the kidnappers denies having
seen him and even threatens to call the
police however when Lucy comes up with a
story that the boy is her sick brother
he eventually gives in the cashier
reveals that JFK is heading to Palo Alto
with a group of teenagers who are
driving a red BMW in the next scene we
see JFK on his way to Palo Alto with his
new friends he tries explaining to them
that he was kidnapped by a bunch of
mysterious Folks by a bunch of
mysterious folks but no one believes him
just then he experiences a sharp pain in
his stomach so Kelly and her group start
driving towards the hospital on the
other hand Wyatt and team are in Hot
Pursuit of the BMW but they just can't
seem to track it Wyatt talks to his Tech
Guys and learns that the BMW changed
course just a few miles from here Lucy
being a history teacher knows very well
that JFK had a history of illness which
made him visit the hospital regularly so
she hypothesizes that the teenagers are
probably headed to a nearby hospital to
get him checked the tech guys then scan
the area where the BMW changed course
and find one hospital nearby in the
meantime we see JFK at a hospital he is
astounded to see the state-of-the-art
facility and the equipment present there
turns out that modern medicine cured his
stomachache instantly meanwhile while
Kelly approaches him and mentions that
she is getting late for her home party
and has to leave she then proposes to
call one of JFK's relatives to pick him
up but he stays silent all of a sudden
he makes Kelly promise to not disclose
what he is about to say and when the
latter obliges he tells her everything I
was kidnapped in the year 1934 and
teleported in the present world I
arrived here in a time machine however
Kelly deduces that he is hallucinating
on medicine and doesn't believe a word
that he is saying also why are you
talking like you're given a speech she
then decides to take him home where he
can get some help at the same time Wyatt
and his Lifeboat team also arrive at the
same hospital and learn that JFK is
being kept in room number 325 wasting no
time they make their move but when white
is about to reach the said room he
notices that a female Assassin from the
ritten house has also tracked JFK there
alarmed he takes out his gun and follows
the lady inside room 325 only to learn
that JFK has already escaped nonetheless
the two get into a fight and before the
security arrives the female assassin
manages to escape why it is apprehended
for his actions but using his impressive
skills he gets out in less than five
minutes elsewhere Kelly leads JFK to her
house where a large party is going on in
full swing in a stressed State JFK
starts blabbering to everyone that he is
a time traveler that he has a Time trap
I can't do that anymore in a stressed
State JFK starts blabbering to everyone
that he is a time traveler so Kelly
takes him away to her room oh there she
shows him some of her books and the two
start bonding over their shared interest
in literature just then Kelly searches
teenage pictures of JFK on her iPad and
compares the two she is shocked to learn
that the guy next to her is actually
John F Kennedy and that he is a time
traveler she then shows him her iPad and
reveals that he will be appointed as the
35th President of the United States in
1961 leaving him speechless JFK asks if
the iPad has information on his brother
Joe so Kelly searches Wikipedia for him
after reading his bio she discloses that
Joe left his college and enlisted in the
Marines during the second world war he
was deployed to France but never came
back as the Nazis shot him dead JFK is
devastated to hear the news but little
does he know that that news is only the
tip of the iceberg Kelly brings up an
article called the Kennedy curse which
states that many members of the Kennedy
family died very young for instance
JFK's sister died in a plane crash and
his other brother perished in a vehicle
collision JFK also learns that he
himself was assassinated in Dallas by a
random guy in 1963 the Revelation sends
shivers down his spine but Kelly
encourages him that he can change his
fate they'll give him false hope Kelly
on the other hand Wyatt and his Lifeboat
team searched the entire area but find
no clues on JFK or the BMW just as they
are about to lose hope Lucy suddenly
comes up with an idea since she knows
that the group of teenagers were headed
off to a party there must be Instagram
pictures of the event and if there are
such pictures JFK must be in at least
one of them hearing this Wyatt quickly
orders his Tech Team to run some face
scans on Instagram and surprisingly
after some effort they find JFK if that
wasn't cable TV hacking at its finest I
don't know what is The Tech Guys then
track the address from the picture and
provide it to Wyatt back at the party
JFK has started drinking excessively
after finding out that he and most of
his family members are going to die soon
Kelly tries to cheer him up by showing
him an American coin with his face on it
but it doesn't do anything just then why
it comes through the door and requests
JFK that they head home the latter
pretends to oblige but at the last
second he pushes Wyatt and runs away to
the main hall where all the teenagers
are partying suddenly the female
Assassin from earlier shows up and
points her gun at JFK she is about to
finish him off but Wyatt arrives in the
nick of time and shoots her first with
this chaos ensues and everyone starts
running left right and center the female
assassin who is now injured takes
advantage of the situation and flees the
scene after the commotion JFK finally
realizes that Wyatt and his friends are
the good guys who are trying to save him
from the bad guys so he decides to trust
them and do what they say before leaving
he bids Kelly an emotional farewell and
thanks her for all that she has done for
him Kelly who probably shouldn't have
shown him that Wikipedia page wishes him
all the best and mentions that it has
been a great honor to spend time with
the greatest president of all time she
also Promises to Keep the whole incident
a secret later the Lifeboat team arrives
at their base with JFK and prepares the
time machine to send him back to his
original time I.E 1934 one of the tech
guys named Martin approaches the
soon-to-be president and warns him to
not reveal any of this time travel stuff
to anyone seriously dude please don't
Martin also warns him against going to
that doomed Dallas rally of 1963 where
he is going to get assassinated you
would think Time Travelers would know
better than to mess with time travel
like that JFK obliges and soon gets
seated inside the time machine the very
next second he disappears and returns
back to his time after a while the same
Tech Guy Martin anxiously approaches his
colleagues and asks what they know about
John F Kennedy he believes that he has
saved the president by informing him
about his death event however to his
horror one of the colleagues says the
JFK was indeed assassinated in 1963.
Martin asserts that it is impossible as
he had strictly told JFK to stay away
from Dallas but the colleague reveals
that he was actually assassinated in
Austin this means that no matter what
they do the timeline will always find a
way to correct the anomalies caused by
time travel the show ends as all the
heroes of the Lifeboat team get ready
for their next time travel Adventure God
Spade subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching